[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right hold on this one turns it off
right yeah the middle one turns away
yeah i had to have the light on because
the lady from the homeowner's insurance
was in here taking pictures of
everything
in case anything gets stolen or the ship
runs down or something
you know what i mean
um yeah danny rolled on now but uh said
he just saw the omen for the first time
oh you've never seen that it was pretty
good and he was like looking forward to
the rest of the series i was like wow i
bet you know i guess that could happen
that's i really like the omen it's still
kind of like one of my comfort food kind
of movies that whole series is good it
is yeah i actually do uh like all the
first one's the best one but um but the
other ones are good too i like the last
one yeah they're all pretty kick-ass
yeah
um final conflict and [ __ ] yeah
so i felt kind of bad that we got cut
off yesterday but we were having a [ __ ]
of a time with the connection we
couldn't really get it to come back on
and the storm hit so yeah i think it
might have been that because there was
like a storm coming yeah and uh i didn't
really realize it i thought it was just
kind of like rainy but then like a
little bit after that lightning yeah it
was just kind of like
oh it's because i never watched the
weather it affected it somewhere else i
mean we were mostly done talking about
the movie anyway yeah the crocodile
movie yeah so uh oh a couple things i
wanted to say uh murder hornet said i'm
glad you're here because
i i got your present and i forgot to put
them on screen and i wanted to show them
i have them back there like but i had
them back there but i forgot to put them
on screen a little bit look at these
look how cool they are mexicans yeah i
got these the other day
yeah
super cool i like the back of them those
are like really cool yeah i love that
and then today
i'm not entirely sure who it's from
but today we got a box from chewie and
it was addressed to pookie ashford
yeah
it's a big old box of those damn
chew sticks she loves those sheba meat
sticks
yeah so thank you whoever set those
because man she is like a big fan i was
about half asleep and jenny put him in
the put him next i said oh look somebody
says
and i went back to sleep i was kind of
dozing back off on her
and and pookie was [ __ ] digging
through that all the piles she jumped at
the box what the [ __ ]
she can recognize them she goes look
oh yeah yeah it's bouncing down put them
in a drawer and she's we're trying
we told you we're trying to like ration
them yeah because i got a bunch like the
other day but yeah because she doesn't
she likes the other flavors like there's
chicken and salmon and something and
beef i think she likes those but they're
kind of uh
yeah but the tuna ones for some reason
she [ __ ] sh she will take those over
temptations yeah like they've knocked
temptations off the top of this yeah
she's now trying to live off of those
damn meat sticks yeah she keeps coming
in the room like every couple minutes
and like going to the drawer and she
like meets another one yeah that's like
no and then she gives you like a little
face like
yeah and then she starts banging like no
and she's oh
and then and then she just looks she big
eyes like she looks at you like you're
all sad you're cuter
trying to look sad
really and you're like god damn it
[Laughter]
because she knows if she looks at you
cute enough long enough then she'll get
one because you can't stand it like with
her little face but
yeah
uh all right so rc yeah the official
call of burt reynolds
it's rocking [ __ ] and cola yes [ __ ]
royal crown
no need for me too says tom's quote of
the day man does she live off those meat
sticks yeah
yeah the girl living off that meat
sticks right now so dirt every man's
fancy it's not just one's man's meat
sticks it's meat sticks coming from
every [ __ ] direction
all the sizes and flavors of meat sticks
all right so this is a good movie last
night we saw a
[ __ ] burt reynolds it's not burt
reynolds it's charles bronson this is
completely distinct
charles bronson movie was called the
assassination was just called
assassination
it had like i think initially this is it
was going to be called the president's
wife yeah uh and it was called that for
a really long time and they're like nah
we don't really want to call it that
like charles bronson was like yeah i
thought it was disrespectful and also
he's like that doesn't really sound like
a movie that charles bronson would be in
uh so then they changed it to the
assassin
um but then they're like no we're gonna
change it to just like assassination
yeah
so you had been wanting to see this for
a while it's free on youtube yeah and
it's a canon movie it's a candy yeah we
didn't know that it was a canon movie it
was like a little bit of a later canon
film i feel like they
because when did cannon go to business
like late 80s early 90s yeah this was
eight this was 87. it was around this
time that it went up and you can tell
that no not just [ __ ] on the movie
because it is pretty entertaining but
you can tell that this was a pretty low
budget yeah pretty low budget but
they're they're trying to
they're they're trying to show you a
[ __ ] movie jenny called it because
man this is like america [ __ ] out of
the movie
it is this is definitely i kind of feel
like all of all of canon's movies in the
80s were um collectively america [ __ ]
yeah the movie yeah you know what i mean
yeah that was kind of their whole like
niche in the market yeah it's every [ __ ]
okay this this movie is every american
stereotype kind of just woven into this
[ __ ] narrative
and it turns out that it it is an action
movie eventually it gets and it's it's
borrowing from [ __ ]
from [ __ ] delta delta force from
chuck norris
all kinds of all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
happens in it
chuck norris plays like head of chuck
norris does not mean he's checking
charles brown charles brown again it's
two
is there something else in that rc that
you're not telling us about
charles bronson
plays like uh he's like head of the
[ __ ] security details he's like
secret service secret service for the
for the for the uh for the first lady
and
all kinds of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] happened
to this
like charles bronzo's wife's in it she's
playing the presidency ireland yeah jill
ireland this is like a couple years
before she died she this is her first
movie after her breast cancer treatment
yeah it's like three years after so it
was like she hadn't made a movie about
three years but she looks great in it um
it's hard to believe that she's like 50
in the movie she looks really she's 50
or 51 yeah something like that looks
really young real cute um
and uh but they me and jenny were always
talking about like a way they dressed
back then [ __ ] in the 80s it was just
the generation gap that's [ __ ]
amazing you know but all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] happens in this movie they [ __ ]
go everything is patriotic as [ __ ] all
right everyone looks like a [ __ ]
secret agent
everyone looks like a [ __ ] republican
in this
yeah everybody looks like nancy reagan
everybody looks like nancy everybody has
big huge hair
with feathers and i kind of laughed
because there was one point where there
was like an explosion or gunfire or
something like that and one of the one
of the uh women the uh it's
now now you got me doing it i was gonna
i almost said chuck norris uh charles
bronson's partner
um
she like dives for the ground and i kind
and i laughed my ass off because her
hair like this wings of her hair just
went
like in one piece because of all the
hairs right and then like the back was
back there and i'm like yep it's that's
the 80s all right it's like this one
like two wings of air moving like that
charles bronson's sidekick is like this
little uh vietnamese uh chick
who's coming on to him through the whole
[ __ ] movie and it's kind of
unrealistic as [ __ ] i mean she's like 30
or 40 years younger than him
yeah she's probably in her mid-30s uh in
this movie
and i guess
charlie is supposed to be playing a guy
in his early 50s i guess but he's
clearly a guy in his [ __ ] mid to late
60s
he looks okay for his age you know but
this is not the same child this is not a
50 year old or a 40 year old charles
bronson you can you can tell okay
um he still does a great job acting i
mean he's he's making his money he's
being charles bronson
but it's just
it's uncomfortable this [ __ ]
relationship it's a little creepy yeah
and then it's a little creepy she's
[ __ ] she's [ __ ] jocking in like
you know like she's fantasizing i guess
it's not really buying it it's less
creepy because she's more of the
instigator he's just kind of like no we
just like work together
he never says like you're too young for
me even though she obvious very
obviously is
but yeah um she does like just keep
trying to ride that dick so every time
she sees him she makes like some kind of
sexual innuendo yeah well and then
finally finally he gives in yeah and
you know
you know me and jd were talking about it
it wasn't so much as his age it was the
generations
the way he yeah they were very stuffy
the way that they looked and act acted
uh i mean
mick jagger at 60 was
nothing like say you know charles
bronson is 60. big difference you know
yeah that's what i was and i think yeah
and i've said this on the show before
it's done david bowie at 60 was [ __ ]
right he was you know it's not so much
the age yeah it's just their whole the
way they carry themselves their whole
person
yeah [ __ ] like that just nothing sexy
about him nothing
about his clothing well because
you said when they were like in the car
and she was just she was making really
really obvious
like hey you want to have sex want to
have sex and he's just like would you
stop and um
well he didn't do that he kind of like
deflected her kind of like funny funny
but uh you know finally like he hits it
and tom's like oh he's having that asian
experience and i was like yeah and she's
having that grandpa yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was it brought me it brought me to uh
that dynamic right there was bringing me
some stig some cigalism you know what i
mean a bit that was bringing me some
stuff and i kind of feel we're seeing
man you got to see it i mean i don't
think and i'll get into this in a minute
because this is like kind of weird to me
i don't think that that was necessarily
like charles bronson's idea to put her
in the movie i think they wanted to put
her in the movie because jill ireland
who was playing uh the first lady who
was
ostensibly like um you know charles
bronson's actual like other love
interest
i kind of feel like maybe the producers
thought well maybe jill ireland is too
old
so we need to put like a younger hotter
woman
in the movie i'm just saying that that's
how hollywood producers would have seen
it
because jill ireland if she was 50 or 51
in this like i said this was her first
movie that she had made
since she'd gone through breast cancer
treatment
and you know she looks great and she
looks beautiful
but
by 80s standards they would have thought
well she's like too old
so they would have had some they would
have needed another woman in there that
was much younger for like eye candy
well they knew that the audience
probably the average age is probably
about 20. that's what i'm saying
they're saying well it's probably
younger guys watching this so we have to
put like a young hot woman 22 23 but a
lot of guys a lot of guys on vhs that
were watching were teenagers because
there weren't really any other women in
the movie other than those two no
and man there's some [ __ ] wild [ __ ]
one of the boats that they're on is
called the spread eagle
and
patriotic [ __ ] on it it's it's just i
was like that sounds like a porn boat
yeah this movie
this movie seems to have been written by
foreigners who are kind of imagining in
america
you know this is like a foreigner's
interpretation of what it means i'm not
sure who wrote this but you know what it
seems like you know who directed it the
guy who directed it was a guy named
peter hunt
and he actually did a [ __ ] ton of movies
and uh he wasn't a director on a lot of
them but he was an editor and second
unit director he had a [ __ ] on a tv he
directed um on her majesty's secret
service okay
he directed gulliver's travels he was
actually like an editor and or second
unit director on most of the bond films
like the older ones yeah so
yeah they got a good dude i mean this is
might have been one of the one of the
last if not the last film that he did
okay yeah the movie is actually
competently done it looks pretty good um
it's it's low budget but they kind of
did everything they could to get cool
helicopters and guns and motorcycles in
it there's some motorcycle chase scenes
a lot of [ __ ]
charles bronson shooting [ __ ] 84 law
rockets and dudes on motorcycles uh
assassins showing up with [ __ ] rare
uh
uh rare machine guns like there's a uh
i think richard no it's not richard i
don't remember the name of the the
company but there was a little boutique
shop that made something called the m16k
which was a 10 inch [ __ ] collapsible
stock [ __ ] m16 had adjustable gas
ports on it back in the back in the late
80s that gun was hot as [ __ ] they didn't
make very many of them it was just a
little commando carbine with one of the
assassins shows up with that that was a
trip little little short triangular
round hand guards i think and no front
sight
front sight was in the carrying handle
weird
just uh
i don't know why they did that it's just
something you could it was made in
california but they had a lot of neat
guns hk pistols
uh or or yeah it was an hk i think it
was the vp9 i think is what that thing
was called or that's the new one
just you can look up there's a database
that shows like guns
of whatever movie you want you can just
google it and it it came up and i looked
at all the guns that were in there
rockets and rocket launchers and [ __ ]
there's a lot there's a lot of rocket
launchers yeah a lot of rocket launchers
complaining
a lot of mac 10s
uh there's one scene where
charles brown jumps on a [ __ ] dirt
bike is chasing another guy across the
field and he shoots him with a mac 10
and i think the mac 10 was mounted to
the handlebars of the motorcycle
wasn't it it looked like it looked like
it was i mean because it looked like he
was i mean this was crazy there was also
one where he was in a speedboat and the
bad guy was on a jet ski yeah and they
were shooting at each other
like from the and i was just like
obviously no one was hitting drunk [ __ ]
because you know could you right but you
know what i mean so uh we didn't even
talk about the plot of this movie so the
plot of this movie yeah jill ireland
plays the first lady now uh it's it's a
new administration that's coming right
in a new presidential administration
okay
now charles bronson plays a guy named
jay killian
or kylie as he's known by
by his sidekick
and uh so i guess that under the
previous administration he was like high
up like on presidential protection duty
but
for whatever reason he gets what he
feels is a demotion because he's like
now now that the new administration has
come in now you're gonna be assigned to
the first lady or one mama uh to her
security detail
now just like in a lot of these movies
particularly in the 80s uh
they really do not hit it off uh jill
ireland as the first lady her name's
laura right yeah like laura may like
laramie yeah um because there's a whole
thing about that
uh she is like
a deeply unpleasant woman who does not
think that she needs a security detail
she just wants to do whatever the [ __ ]
she wants to do uh she really does not
like charles bronson so you know they're
gonna kind of fall in love later on um
and she's kind of like everybody talks
about her like she's this ball breaking
uh [ __ ] and a half you know what i mean
what do they did that one guy calls her
an era nut at some point is he talking
about her no he's talking about
or he was talking about another he
didn't call her dr and uh he called her
a uh
a woman's rights
nut
she was one of the women's rights nuts
she kept pat me on the ass that was
[ __ ] how i started laughing deal with
it [ __ ]
is
i just thought it was very funny
cultural artifact of the times
where
a guy was thinking that well she's a
women's right advocate she is a sexual
aggressor you know she's the sexist pig
that was the interpretation of the time
i just laughed there's a lot of funny
[ __ ] in this movie it was very funny a
lot of funny [ __ ] in this movie it was
very funny and i don't think that was
intended it was just
it might not have been i know yeah yeah
there was a lot of [ __ ] in the movie
that was just funny i think
unintentionally just aged so weird yeah
just [ __ ] hillary so yeah so she's a
very very unpleasant person and she
keeps trying to like uh give everybody
the slip because like i said she just
wants to do what the [ __ ] she wants to
do and she's like i don't like this
first lady [ __ ] where everybody's like
watching me all the time which i you
know i can't blame her so uh yeah so she
does this one thing where she goes to
they go to slam big like to do
and she puts on what is very obviously a
terrible disguise like she's supposed to
be like a hippie
or something but she comes out with this
like ridiculous wig like a fringed
leather jacket
and she has like a little radio and
she's like dancing all weirdly which you
would think would like draw even more
attention she's supposed to be kind of
like a early heavy metal chick who
listened to say like you know bon jovi i
guess that's that's what that's supposed
to be oh we weren't red again
hold on hold on hold on hold on
come on come back okay yeah she's
supposed to be like somebody a bon jovi
fan with the fringe on the jacket was
that what it was she looked kind of
hippie-ish to me but no
i it was 87 that was a little late for
him yeah although there was like a
hippie
like resurgence in the late 80s early
90s i feel like so maybe it was that i
don't really know i can't believe we're
losing this stream again is it gonna
storm again i don't know i don't know i
mean maybe it'll be all right we'll just
just keep talking we're fine
but um
yeah
so she escapes out from under but
charles bronson is on to her
so he kind of follows her and then he's
like okay you know whatever i'll just
like we'll go on this cross-country
thing because like i said they did do
some shots in washington dc for this but
this is what i mean when i'm saying that
canon was like saving money on the [ __ ]
because
i feel like they probably used stock
footage of the buildings i would imagine
or they did kind of like a film and run
because i'm imagining getting permits to
film some of that stuff wasn't cheap
even in the 80s
um
some of the stuff that they filmed
outside was clearly clearly not dc
because there were palm trees
so there was that
and also uh a lot of the movie like
after the first lady like takes off
there's kind of they kind of go
on the road so it's like a road trip
these assassins like trying to kill her
and charles bronson is like trying to
figure out why people want to kill her
um and for a while they do kind of like
a red herring thing where maybe
the assassins are trying to kill him
although they never really go too much
into that i don't think they maybe they
did and i didn't catch it
get a poke
okay maybe this is actually connected
yeah okay i'm just waiting for it to go
green and waiting for the kilobytes per
second to go back okay um so yeah so
they're trying to set up like this
burgeoning romance between the two of
them like i said who were married in
real life at the time were actually
married until she died three years after
this came out
and
the weird thing about it though is that
they make it kind of like okay
by
essentially saying yeah me and the
president like we have an understanding
yeah she's like i just married him
because i liked him he was my friend and
he needed a wife like when he was
running for office because nobody trusts
a bachelor blah blah but essentially
they don't say this outright but i think
this is what they mean essentially uh he
got his dick shot off in the war right
or he already he was in a plane crash
and it made him quote unquote impotent
so i was like so he lost his dick in the
war that's what you're saying so um so
the fact that yeah they said they i
think they just said that because he
said he read the files so he must yeah
he was gone
that's what i mean that's what i took
from it they didn't say that right but i
thought i kind of read between the lines
yeah i was like yeah he lost his dick
into work impotent [ __ ] they could fix
that
that's what i was saying yeah that's an
impact i said it had to be something a
little bit more than that put it down
he's like smooth like a ken doll down
yeah
they just put a damn balloon in that
[ __ ] dude pumping it up on his nut i
mean we shouldn't laugh but because some
people do have that i have that problem
but i just thought it was funny that
they wanted to like make this romance
between them okay
by saying well you know i don't have sex
with him even though we're married and i
just married him for convenience like
for political reasons and you know after
he
you know
won like now we're thinking about like
going our way own way because i don't
she's like because i don't really like
being under the scrutiny all the time i
like to just like live my own life but
then the weird thing about it is that
they set all of that up
but then charles bronson ends up with
the young yeah i mean they don't like
they leave it a little bit ambiguous
because she says what what the [ __ ] was
her name what was her i don't know i
can't remember what her character's name
was the characters are just
she wasn't that that actress wasn't in a
lot of movies she's actually she's a
dancer yeah um she was in a chorus line
and she was in some other so that's she
was more a dancer than an actor she was
only in like three movies uh including
this one
and so i thought that was really weird
and i was like how weird would it be
like
uh because charles bronson and jill
ireland were in i'm just gonna keep
doing this apparently
i just i just didn't want you to okay i
think it's back on oh it should be good
it's good
yeah it was look it's a canon movie
they were kind of made for kids uh
[Laughter]
you weren't supposed to think about it
you the you just watch the thing to see
some people shoot each other and [ __ ]
some motorcycles and uh to see some [ __ ]
blow up and they're trolling you through
the whole [ __ ] movie name of the butt
was spread eagle
i mean all kinds of [ __ ] all kinds of
[ __ ] happened that was like they were
trolling i was like what
it was good you know it was
what i don't even remember all the
[ __ ] trolls that they can't came at a
camera i don't either but actually like
really coming
particularly funny to me was like i said
the the girl that was his partner
um like every single time she saw him
she was basically she would say
something like she would come in his
hotel room be like those pants going on
or coming off yeah you know what i mean
it was like i was like oh my god she's
[ __ ] thirsty well she's supposed to
be the comedic relief yeah she's the
clown of the movie really you know
and he's not really
i don't you're not supposed to take it
seriously he doesn't take it seriously
it almost seems like they're joking he's
just like whatever we work together i'm
not going there right but then he does
go there yeah
and then he says stuff like
didn't he say it didn't he say at some
point too that she was like um you know
oh she asked why don't you move in here
with me and he says i might die from
terminal orgasm yeah
charles brown yeah i mean i'm pretty
sure it was almost exactly like that
yeah that's what he said yeah terminal
orgasm there at the stupid
it's back
i don't know what the [ __ ] is up with
this [ __ ] i don't either
it's like you know
yeah it's reconnected and it's weak
yeah it's like i guess okay well the
weather's shitty and it's just like i
kind of hope that it
there's some data going up i guess yeah
i mean i hope that it straightens itself
out before to the show yeah we'll see
what to see you know okay it's green
again now yeah some people are like get
you know
logging off because it's like two it's
keeps buffering all right let's go ahead
and shut it down then i mean we pretty
much finished it yeah we did so uh so
yeah sorry about this you guys i'm gonna
try and figure out something else uh you
know
maybe maybe you have to get that thing
rolling is that working yeah you got
that working okay yeah that is working
that's why i don't understand like why
it's still [ __ ] up on me but yeah so
um hopefully this will be sorted out by
tomorrow evening we're doing the show
about
the dingo ate my baby case okay which
would be the death of azaria chamberlain
so hopefully you can all make it for